back here at home metro police are  investigating two homicides this evening  the first happened just east of the mgm  grand on the south end of the strip near  tropicana and koval  police say the shooting happened after  an argument at an apartment  when officers got there they found a man  dead with a gunshot wound  an investigation revealed that the  suspect was recently released from  prison in california moved here  the suspect had a friend over and the  two allegedly got into an argument  that's when those shots were apparently  fired the suspect has not been arrested  if you have any information please call  crime stoppers